[Music]
the coronavirus crisis is having a
dramatic impact on us we have lost so
far tens of thousands of people in the
European Union to this virus our health
care systems aren't an enormous strain
and our economy is severely hit many
people fear for their lives and also for
their jobs defeating this virus requires
unprecedented measures even before the
first cases were reported in the
European Union we took steps to prepare
for this disease
[Music]
[Music]
soon we also started to help bring back
European citizens stranded across the
world
[Music]
at the same time we swiftly mobilized
funding for research because we need
vaccines new treatments and better
diagnosis methods to fight this virus
[Music]
the dramatic outbreak in Wuhan made us
quickly recognize its serious risks to
public health worldwide one of our first
priorities was therefore calling out to
member states to raise their
preparedness coordinate on all levels
and demonstrate international solidarity
firstly toward China as well as among
each other
[Music]
as the virus spread rapidly throughout
the European Union we stepped up our
response on all fronts medical economic
mobility Civil Protection and many more
[Music]
we need the best scientific evidence to
fight this virus and this is why I
gathered a team of leading European
experts to advise us
we could step to help ensure that our
hospitals have the equipment they need
the Commission has been working with
industry to ramp up production of
protective and medical equipment such as
ventilators and it is helping member
states buy equipment through joint
procurement
member states first reaction was to
impose border controls these led to
significant waiting times at some border
crossings of more than 24 hours we have
worked intensively with national
governments to overcome the blockage and
the lace we acted fast to unblock
traffic to enable people to reach their
homes or workplaces and to make sure
that goods could be delivered where they
were needed from hospitals to shops
[Music]
and because the containment measures hit
the economy we have unlocked funding to
fight the crisis we provided billions of
euros in support from the EU budget and
we adapted the rules to enable
governments to pump money in the economy
to protect people's jobs and to keep
businesses running support measures are
more than three trillion euros have been
announced so far in the European Union
this is the most impressive response
anywhere in the world
[Music]
in parallel we are working with our
international partners on a coordinated
global response that's the only way to
beat the virus
we have made real progress by working
closely together in the EU against the
coronavirus the spread of the virus has
started to slow down now we are working
with governments to help ensure a
gradual and coordinated lifting of
containment measures when the right time
comes
[Music]
we are also working on a robust recovery
plan to kick-start our economy and
create jobs for Europeans and to make
Europe stronger and more resilient